[Music]
hi hello everyone welcome back to the
lobby GameSpot's weekly video game
hangout here in San Francisco California
every Wednesday I'm your host Mike
McCarty here with V reviews editor Brown
dancer Peter Brown hi that was a cool
pre-show loop that we ran a little
callback toe and you did a link between
worlds joke I'm not at all ashamed to
say that I am really proud of that yeah
I was rolling for a while I edit account
leap laggy and rot handler II what do
you actually what do you do here oh I
was kidding
this is fun video producer Rob handler
we're here as usual kind of a light week
but also kind of not we're busy with a
lot of destiny to beta stuff we'll be
getting to that during the show our
initial impressions for a Bungie sequel
which comes out in September not crazy
far away
splatoon to Kelley your review is
finally up we talked about single-player
last week but now we can dive into
single-player a little more although we
can't talk past a certain point yeah
yeah dive into some multiplayer yes some
multiplayer stuff too as well now that
the flow review is up you eight out of
ten we can talk more about that also Evo
the fighting game tournament happened
last weekend in Vegas richard lee who's
here in the studio behind the cameras
right now is also there playing some
street fighter
maybe yeah no yeah he's saying yes and
then we're just gonna get into a few
news bits today as usual we do have a
giveaway as usual but I'm gonna hold out
to the end of the show and goob don't
try going into the GameSpot twitch chat
after Shiva posted on Twitter cuz I told
her to hold off so two steps ahead of
you buddy cool so news not a lot of
Kingdom Hearts love in the office I have
since discovered since we talked about a
Kingdom Hearts 3 we talked to Tatsuya
Nomura the director on why the game is
taking so long I think it was an event
where they interviewed him after d23
because they know it's a toy stories
involved with Kingdom Hearts now for
some reason Pete you were thinking is
funny that we were the only like outlet
to ask what's taking so long
I mean I didn't read absolutely every
interview but from the coverage I saw we
were the only ones that really just sort
of asked that question outright mm-hmm
cuz yeah well I don't forget when they
announced this game it's been 12 years
since Kingdom Hearts 2 came out on ps2
but yeah they announced three
see in a second but yeah essentially
they they I'm conflated - switching to
Unreal Engine 4 took of Rights launched
its mannequins and moving staff around
for a couple projects it's it's not
surprising yeah but I feel like they
show so little of this game that it's
hard to believe that they've made this
much progress yeah they want us to think
yeah they showed up here's Andy's
bedroom of Toy Story Fame so that'll be
making its way into Kingdom Hearts 3
with soar last sort oh okay he looks
like a toy I was gonna say well he looks
really different they also a lot of
Kingdom Hearts fans so I really do like
the first Kingdom Hearts I don't like
the second one and I don't care about
like dream Drop Distance or 358 by two
days or birth by Sleep whatever it's
called but I do like the first game but
I'm not crazy excited for the third one
I feel like that's one of those games
where you know after Final Fantasy 15
and the Last Guardian finally came out I
wonder if this will complete that trend
of these games we've been waiting for
forever coming out just to equate a few
very different games for no reason but
yeah we saw some Toy Story stuff they
said the gummi ship is coming back for
for lay people the gummi ship actually
transporting for lame people no it
totally is really dumb it's the it
transports you between the dimensions in
this case different Disney worlds I
really never understood it
you've started off on an island in the
first game with a few of your friends
Riku and Kairi and renamed people from
early Final Fantasy games which I didn't
even know until recently not Riku and
Kairi but like what's his name Sid isn't
the first Kingdom Hearts hmm
but I also plague Tina parts before I
really even like care about Final
Fantasy especially because I really
still don't care about final fantasy
that much but I did like the first one
but yeah we asked him he said switching
over to Unreal Engine 4 was kind of a
change planning on the game for a little
while but he also seemed kind of a
little bit defensive maybe not defensive
but he said a lot of people have been
mentioning and making it sound like oh
no Morris taking too much time and it
hurts there was a decision made to
change to an external Unreal Engine 4
sorry an external engine in this case
Unreal Engine 4 so we switched over to
that unfortunately there was a bit of
time that need to be rewound and started
over there so there's a bit of a setback
there but it was a decision that
company had to make so it was inevitable
but he was also careful to say that it
was not any problems with development
and that it's going smoothly
I mean he came off of you know being
taken off of Final Fantasy Versus 13
mm-hmm before that became 15 so I think
he's raised he's right to feel a little
bit downtrodden what else does he worked
on besides that is that chrono trigger
Final Fantasy 7 I mean pretty much many
squares and Squaresoft RPGs over the
years I think you like as early as
kernel trigger he was doing maybe like
background art or something like that
but that's that's where he first cut his
teeth and he's been involved in a lot of
things ever since cool yeah so these
toys look dangerous mm-hmm Andy's
driveway right there yeah so I don't
know who was seeing more if you want to
go read that full interview we had a few
news stories out of it but yeah Micro
Joe down and ah he's our new
entertainment editor down at d23 he got
to talk to numerous so you can go read
that full one up on gamespot.com in
other news doom fists whoo people might
have played on overwatch PTR a couple
weeks ago is officially coming to all
platforms on July 27th he is the attack
character that was kind of alluded to
and a lot of the lore from the game on
uh there's a lot of random kind of story
hints on new mum-mum Bonnie no Bonnie if
I'm saying that correctly yeah he will
actually be coming to the game fully not
just on PTR very shortly in a few days
actually and he's not voiced by Terry
Crews yeah
which a lot people are disappointed
about including Terry Crews yeah let's
get this akamaru's I mean like that's
never a good thing I just feel like his
voice so recognizable right like you
wouldn't want enough if people were like
diehard on that like casting but but you
do Memphis where's Old Spice probably
mm-hmm I did like a crisp rare hour news
editor put a story about doom fist up
and it was like Terry not doom fist Cruz
and I quite liked that nickname so at
least we got that joke
of it yes here he is someone hearing
doom fest in Kingdom Hearts 3 he's got
the chat pretty amped for the
possibility of that happening yes so
you'll be able play that in July 27th on
all three platforms so go do that kind
of in more entertainment side of things
we saw a behind-the-scenes video for
Star Wars Episode eight which comes out
this December
directed by Rian Johnson so he had some
commentary in it Daisy Ridley John
boyega they're all talking about how
this movie what they said it they said
it's good I'm sure they wouldn't say
otherwise but they're saying it's super
unexpected how what he's doing with Star
Wars
you know remains to be seen whether it
will be but they showed a few more like
new aliens and kind of creatures that we
haven't seen before I don't know Rob
you're the person who would recognize
this more Oh totally so this is
obviously that red planet or the Mars
God dang it there's Chewie there looking
probably pretty depressed near camp fire
that's right but you know you're seeing
a lot of these settings the aliens yeah
so they that's what's really cool is I
love seeing the practical effects of
like puppeteering and all you know this
GI and looking things but namely there
are a few shots of I think they're
called porks you'll see him coming up
they were rumored and there's a
subreddit that we're hinting at these
things like one being on like our tubes
head but they're little cute little
almost like Furby like guys that are
supposed to be all over that planet act
- I think we're ray and Luke were left
off and force awakens and this is cool
like it's cool to see like for me at
least like rumors kind of confirmed in
this trailer but yeah you said it like
the the I almost like this more than the
last trailer just because it seems like
they're really going for something
different and that's what we really want
you know like force awakens was meant to
kind of redeem the franchise rogue one
was experimental I want to say this is
where I think they really need to go
like in a different direction because
obviously people the biggest gripe of
the last force awakens was that it was
so similar at a new hope
right as far as all the plot points I
mean after looper and brick and what the
couple of Breaking Bad episodes that he
did which kind of always broke the mold
it seems like Rian Johnson would try to
take the opportunity to do something new
so remains to be seen whether that will
happen I know obviously when you're
working with Lucasfilm there's a lot you
have to respect God so you know you're
still there that thing was cute yeah
that's called porks yeah man just seen
like them rehearsing saber fights like
that was three sabers would look like or
maybe kylo the Knights of Ren attacking
Rey and then kylo there with like two uh
two lightsabers he was battling like I
don't know I think we're gonna see a lot
of saber action which is exciting hmm
I can't wait for this movie yeah yep and
then another movie news sound right here
I got to see Dunkirk so his reveal be up
soonish the new Christopher Nolan World
War two movie about the English escaping
back to throw over the channel with like
sated by civilians but in true nolan
fashion I'm sure it'll kind of do
something weird with the maybe timeline
or something who knows or maybe it'll be
more down-to-earth something different
for him I'm pretty excited I don't think
I had any luck finding tickets for the
weekend really no well yeah well in all
fairness I didn't look I had Jake look
for me my friend Jake I had him check
what I don't want to go on record
calling him my boy assistant he said
that he all the seats were kind of like
shitty front row stuff so I don't know
we'll see cool moving on from that we
also heard that Casey Hudson of Bioware
Fame is going back to Bioware Erin Flynn
the general manager of the Edmonton or
the studio in general was leaving after
17 years he'd most recently worked on in
drama de I know he did a lot of work on
anthem which we saw at e3 before he left
yeah it was all in good grace he just
said he wanted to make change his life
and so they brought Casey Hudson back
who directed the original Mass Effect
trilogy so it's pretty exciting a lot of
movement on that studio even during
Andromeda development which you know you
have to wonder how much that played into
the final product but that's come and
gone
they refuted that whole claim that there
will be no DLC for it apparently forget
what the original pork report came from
but yeah Casey Hudson's coming back to
work on anthem I'm pretty excited for
anthem mainly just because I want to see
Bioware get back on top in terms of like
storytelling role-playing games a lot of
people are comparing it to destiny but
Bioware was quick to reassure everyone
that would be very narrative heavy kind
of like most of what they're known for
ya know one of the e3 stuff didn't do
anything for me I don't just see more
from that pretty lukewarm yeah I'm like
it doesn't no no no it looks very
generic to me I I am withholding my
excitement until they show me something
that is worthy of you know getting
excited about yeah grounded dreams the
twitch I was saying it was British
French Belgian and Canadian troops
involved in Dunkirk evacuation so my
apologies to anybody from Belgium France
or Canada God yeah yeah so I'm I'm
excited to see what they do I can't
imagine it'd be any major shakeups I
mean he's had experience so it sounds
like he's gonna be kind of involved with
a few different things between studio
management and actual creative direction
for anthem and anything else him to come
out they've been Mike Laidlaw the Dragon
Age head has been saying they're hiring
for a new Dragon Age project which is
exciting as someone who liked origins
didn't really like Inquisition or Dragon
Age 2 I I'd like to see maybe they'll
take a chance to go back and do
something new but they also have on yeah
obviously anthem and this I like the
free travel I'm totally with you Kelly
it doesn't really this alone is not
enough to get me like super back on
board I think I think like lately
bioroids left a bad taste in my mouth
with the last few things they've pushed
out but it does look cool I mean to be
super you know like cursory it looks fun
and obviously we were playing destiny 2
which we will get to in a little bit
after playing the beta for the last
couple days but people are comparing it
to destiny and in terms of this like
almost you know shared multiplayer
experience but coop and kind of loot
driven but who knows what anthem will be
when we see more of it a lot of people
are just think the Iron Man mech suits
look super cool which I'm on board with
so remains to be seen what Casey Hudson
will do now these back of the studio but
good news all around
best wishes they're influenced what he's
doing in the future now that he's
leaving by our Callie and Pete actually
undertale ps4 vita got a release date
august 15th and i wanted to take the
opportunity as someone who has never
played the game but has been meaning to
you for a long time
sell me on why i should play this game
on August 15th buy it play it get into
it I know it's semi short and I don't
you don't really need to sell me cuz I
want to play it but if if people don't
know what this is and they have a ps4
and no other console why should they
play this well for I wouldn't consider
it short I think if you really want to
get the most I'm under tell you to play
it I would encourage you to play it
several times I've wanted to play it
several times but yeah undertale is an
you know heavily earthbound inspired RPG
that basically bends your expectations
of the genre and consistently surprised
me and there was a moment like it's a
very beginning of the game where I don't
a spoil anything but I did something
that you would normally do in an RPG and
the game totally called me out on it and
then I was sold from there I think it's
fantastic as you can see it's also being
released in Japanese which would be
really fun to play handled by eight for
a lot of low they do like localization
stuff they do like Fire Emblem they do
all sorts tougher Nintendo Capcom yeah
you've played their games for sure yeah
stuff they've worked on it's also really
challenging and there's a couple
different runs where like I struggled a
lot with some of these boss battles so
I'm wondering if maybe not doing it
mouse and keyboard would help I also
played on my macbook so I'm very excited
to play on I'll probably get it on Vita
I think it would find a very good home
on beat up but I really want that
collector's edition because it comes
with a locket and this is creepy looking
but yeah it's like like I said it's very
it's very like irreverent and self-aware
and tongue-in-cheek lots of internet
humor so if you're not into that you're
you might be annoyed with some of this
stuff annoying dog is fantastic is that
like a laundry duct around that person's
arm apologies to people who say on the
pretty sure that was toriel's
arms she's got mom as she is fondly
referred to what goes on stops I'm sorry
goat mom yeah Toro who is it's a set of
first characters you mean yes
the story of undertale is you're a child
that falls into the realm of monsters
monsters have been driven underground by
humans and toriel kind of takes you in
and raises you and then you set out on
your own
so very you know typical RPGs set up but
of course it really bends your
expectations of what that is and there's
like I think there's like 10 endings or
something like there's a lot of endings
depending on what you do I've played the
- like pure endings so I'm really
excited to play like other routes in
this game I'm I was telling you I've
been recently side tangent playing near
automata which everybody encourages you
to play through and the more I hear
about it it's less multiple playthroughs
it's more actually different sides of
the same story sometimes yes exactly
yeah I'm so maybe just because I mean we
have no dearth of games to play I always
am hesitant I think it's cool that games
have multiple endings and multiple
playthrough options but it's really
worth doing here taking the time to see
different endings I think so yeah I
think that there's there's one ending
that like I sobbed for like 30 minutes
after I finished it it was so impactful
I mean it's a it's a really emotional
game it's also funny and it's not too
heavy I mean for some of the routes and
I just couldn't I couldn't say enough
good things about it I think it's it's
brilliantly made it's smart and it's
self-aware
I think Toby Fox did a great job with
the writing of the creator and the
characters are all relatable and you
know they start out seeming kind of like
almost like anime archetypes and then
you kind of peel back the layers on them
I mean there's there's so many fantastic
things to uncover even the battle system
is closely intertwined with character
development it's just really really
smart cool yeah I remember a freelancer
did a review for us I believe at the
time 9 out of 10 yeah and you can go
read the four of you if you like myself
have never gotten around to it or maybe
if you just have like a ps4 and Vita and
you want to finally dive into it I'm
excited
do you think you'll replay it yeah
August 15th it's got a really good
soundtrack too
oh yes listen to sound check extensively
for a game I haven't played the music's
phenomenal like that's something like I
I reviewed it before I worked here
that's something that I didn't write
enough about in my review I think like
if I could go back and rewrite it that's
something I would add because I think
it's there's like lots of motifs in the
music and if you like I know very little
about the creation of music but I just I
think it's fantastic the one thing that
people say about is the arts Genki but I
think that gives it charm yeah apex
Penguin and the YouTube chat was saying
the game like changes the game itself
changes throughout the time so I'm
excited to check that out oh he's
talking about illusion of Gaia which
also does that yeah game of soldier I
never played that that does what
illusion of Gaia play that it's worth
many place unless he's talking about oh
okay oh you're still talking about
undertale okay cool there's like three
different games people to YouTube chat
who's your guy oh they're talking about
they're also talking about near
automatics I mention it cool
yeah ultraman osa in the twitch chats
that rob is off the quiet today I just
don't know if undertale is your jam i
don't know enough about that game - yeah
cuz i wont yeah you think you might
really great yeah I actually will
definite slike a pretty awesome list of
reasons yeah I think the one thing I
would say is like I think there is a
specific audience that would like it
more like if you're already really into
RPGs like you will like that like I
would highly recommend it if you're not
into RPGs I would say it's there's
almost that barrier to entry like you
have to have played some older RPGs to
really get the references if you're
patient with it though I think anyone
will like it but I think it's it's worth
playing regardless of your gaming
interests just even on a like an
intellectual level of like learning like
oh this is what a game can do I think
one of the coolest things I could go on
forever I'll stop soon the coolest thing
about undertale to me is that it's
something that only a game could do and
I think the story if you read it in a
you read a short story that was a you
know the same plot as undertale it
wouldn't be nearly as great as it is
told in the video game medium and that's
something that I don't often see with
games stories like a game can have a
phenomenal story but I could also you
know watch the you know the YouTube
compilation of all the cutscenes and
kind of get
Geist you cannot do that with undertale
I think it's just really brilliant use
of the medium damn cool yeah for
something they like as you said that you
had like a 30 minute fry fest yet its
self-aware and like tongue-in-cheek like
that's those are pretty you know spread
out ends of the spectrum like that's
that's crazy to me is it weird that the
way you're talking about it kind of
reminds me of how cabin in the woods is
much better if you really like horror no
I don't think that's where I mean like
that's how I felt about cabin in the
woods also because you have to have gone
into that movie knowing that you know
like going to a cabin in the woods is a
horror trope it's hard to recognize how
some subversive something is if you're
not super familiar with the source
material maybe I don't know but like
pizza undertale sounds good regardless
it's still fun like there's there's sort
of like bullet-hell the boss battles so
even that is just like a undertale yeah
yeah it's like sort of like bullet hell
but it it's dodging yes um and so even
that is just like a dexterity challenge
that can be fun even if you're not
really invested in you know the RPG
stuff cool yeah this is a good excuses
honey for me to finally get it off my
backlog it's been there for what two
years now it came out 2015 fall polish
damn cool awesome so yeah I'll just 15th
if you're on PlayStation 4 you can pick
it up and play a cross play on your Vita
so you've not got the chance to play
that game yet alright
yeah we're for those just joining on
YouTube or twitch our GameSpot we are
gonna get into splatoon too and destiny
to beta impressions which we all here
played a little bit of Destiny at least
I didn't get the chance play splatoon
too but Callie just published her a full
review yesterday yes and people ate it
Rob Pilatus we could talk about that but
first I do want to recap some Evo stuff
yeah some drama between 18-year old
american prodigy people are saying a
victor Punk
yeah Woodley and the Japanese 32 year
old veteran taquito you could call it
drama I think it was is just sort of
Taishan tension you know what I mean
yeah someone people have like likened it
to like a Rocky movie where it's like
this sort of like rollercoaster of like
oh he's on top and no he's not and like
oh should he take his time no he's just
gonna go for it you know basically this
is this eighteen-year-old
showed up punk and he I think
like he was undefeated up until the
champions and one of the one of the guys
he knocked out ended up being able to go
against him in the championship round
but because he came from the losers
bracket he like had to win twice as many
rounds and to clinch the victory and
[ __ ] get away like two sets or something
instead of one precisely and he did and
there was a lot of sort of like you know
back and forth and you know for on
Punk's end because he was sort of just
like trying to push himself through it
and took he don't knew that like okay he
just wants to win so I know he's just
gonna attack me so I'm just gonna push
back and essentially you know use his
desire to be offensive against him yeah
he seed punk here playing Karen and then
Takeo with Akuma but like you were just
saying apparently according I don't know
anything like that move right there
totally unnecessary that was Tokyo
basically being like I'm owning you yeah
I'm going to do a very flashy move yes
and and own you mentally as well at this
point yeah yeah he got into the Blake
you said he kind of nullified punks
aggressive
there's punk right there his aggressive
nature by actually kind of pushing back
really hard and then the apparently Punk
was being defensive even though punk was
a completely undefeated well he lost a
few rounds here and there but right but
no he never lost the match up until the
finals yeah like you said he was the one
that pushed the Kido into the loser's
bracket initially right but yeah
apparently people are saying even if
you're not super familiar with fighting
you can kind of see that the Kido is
taking control the entire time yeah but
yeah that way I think that was the main
event the Street Fighter 5 finals yeah
but there were a lot of like really cool
announcements that probably won't matter
to anyone other than people who have
followed fighting games for a while so
for example geese Howard is going to
Tekken 7 a game filled with awful
daddies and geese Howard is one of the
worst video game dad's ever and he's
being brought into the full what makes
him bad he basically throws his son like
in fatal fury basically like treats his
kids like [ __ ] he uses them as fodder
for his own game ok so then you've also
got the announcement well it's sort of
the the bigger reveal of fighting layer
IX which is Arica is a company that's
made games for and with Capcom for
decades and they are any
fools last year they showed off a
fighting game that looked very similar
to Street Fighter II X and everyone
thought it was fake but then you're like
oh no it's a real game we didn't mean to
confuse anybody it's not a joke
hey first shoot right so we got to see
more of characters we got to see what
that game is really like skullomania is
back which is a big deal if you use sort
of like the lasting legacy of the Street
Fighter II X Games because he's such a
flamboyant interesting character and
everyone's kind of assumed he was done
for like that we weren't gonna see him
again
classically Tamar Hussein loves to
bother any developer relevant to
skullomania about when he's coming back
and lo and behold here we go he looked
pretty awesome yeah I've got da rune
Meister here or mr. looks like that was
like the stance of Aldo can go into its
soul calibur
yeah when you do that crab walk but like
school mania loves did you mention that
sorry did you mention the blaze blue
thing I don't know much about bless blue
no but they did announce something with
blaze blue probably yeah but Dragonball
Z also made a very good showing sorry
John Luke I know John Luke in the back
loves blasts blue I don't I don't know
enough to yeah John Luke quick over the
speakers what is the name of that game
just so I don't
Elian eight anybody who likes that stuff
please blue cross battle blaze blue
cross battle thank you
wait is it blast blew or blaze blue cuz
I've always said blasts blue it's blaze
blue but it's fun to say blasts blue
thank you here's some b-roll really good
looking game yeah the same company that
did that is doing Dragon Ball Z that has
done guilty yeah and all that and
someone brought up a really interesting
point all these games that Arc System
Works makes they're they're super
complicated in ways that don't really
feel necessary all the time mm-hmm
Dragon Ball Z has like a very specific
set of like possibilities and like
abilities from the characters so it's
actually gonna be interesting to see
them have to show some restraint yeah in
terms of their system design in
something that is also very popular
I love trunks so much Ultraman OSA and
the twitch chat said you're not gonna
talk how dragon Walker Trident Russia's
way to become injustice Evo champion so
uh if you want to go more in depth of
that you can go check out YouTube stuff
for that I did not get the chance to
watch it but I will check it out for
sure especially cuz I've been enjoying
just injustice to this year very much I
still kind of jump back into that for a
round or two once or twice a week lastly
it's Repetto v is getting a character
that no one's really thrilled about
abigail this Greg that's Abigail he's
from final fight this is not the first
final fight character in Street Fighter
we've had guy we've had Cody if they
were gonna bring any character from
final fight I really wish it had been
Hagar mm-hmm the mayor who kicks ass in
the streets and is a fantastic daddy as
far as daddies go this is a very very
yeah do you mean father do you mean
daddy why can't I mean both what the
[ __ ] this is
here's a super here's a very very
dangerous tangent I know I'm known for
these but have you guys been tuned in to
what's good there's this slight dreamed
a dream dad dating game I cannot wait
for that yeah some people yes I could
walk you through daddy because I've been
seeing so many like memes this is it
right here what happened with that is
people didn't know that game existed
about a month ago and they announced a
release date like oh this dad's dating
simulator you're gonna play a dad dating
other dads and oh it's dad's dating
dad's you don't just pick a dad to date
I'm pretty sure it's dad real-deal dad
dating I'm pretty sure it's dad dating
there we go dream daddy I could be most
inside joke ever we can explain that
into beca's I probably shouldn't explain
everybody anyway what happened was they
delayed it they were like hey you know
the game is supposed to come out
tomorrow but there were problems we
didn't we weren't happy with the QA
we're going to hold off on releasing it
and people were yes but it was also a
matter of them saying we are killing
ourselves
yeah to finish this film last
we don't feel good the game is going to
suffer as a result in the final stretch
it's better for us and for the game and
ultimately for you the player if we just
take like another week or whatever right
and they basically said like crunch is
really hurting us everyone's tired there
are still bugs to work out we will work
them out for you we want to release a
game that we are proud of that you will
enjoy and like I feel like it's a bunch
of tumblr tumblr girls being like but I
wanted my daddy simulator now and so
people are people are pissed and they
didn't even know this game existed yeah
but like 30 days ago so that's pretty
ridiculous I am very excited to play it
because I imagine it'll be an experience
yeah Errol moss is a regular from in our
chats he's in the twitch chat right now
he's saying yeah it's by Vernon Shaw and
the other members of game grumps and
he's agreeing the outrage was ridiculous
for the same reasons you're saying does
Errol also know if it's dad's dating
dad's or a few dating deaths you're not
a dad yeah he hasn't said yet but
hopefully I've answers I could've sworn
it was you're a dad and you're looking
for daddy screenshot dad who's like come
out of a divorce who is now a new lease
on life you know I realized I was gay
and pretty jacked middle-aged men with
like sleeve tattoos but they're also
holding like their daughters hand yes
that's the screenshots I've seen that's
really the that's the life
jean-luc in the twitch chat just posted
dream daddy a dad dating simulator
parentheses capital D da DDS is a game
where you play as a dad and your goal is
to meet and romance other attractive
dads you're right nailed it I know my
daddy's never mind what kind of there
probably be a lot of like like fan
fiction coming out of this oh this game
seems like it is fan fiction well it
sort of reminds me of huddle by friend
and that it's like a dating simulator
that's just really self-aware like it's
not it's not like a normal dating
simulator you're like should I go for
the jock or should I go for the you know
the nerd who works in the library it's
more like alright am I going for the the
guy with an anchor tattoo who loves his
baby daughter where am I going for the
Posche dad who's actually an [ __ ]
like like that's what I'm at
it's gonna be like so I'm very very
excited there's gonna be me was saying
like mr. Jenkins is best boy oh oh I
will have a best daddy because I have a
best pigeon and boyfriend what's this
pigeons new song he'll what's it like
he's he's cool he's the cool guy oh my
god that was that was brilliant dude
that's what the game does though oh I
thought I made that up no I did but
that's how I mean words that's all bird
puns bird puns
yeah anyway like bird fun anyway
definitely we'll be checking that out
and do not worthy not worth the anger
for sure if I said anchor like that
tattoo again no no not the tattooed and
the anger it's so people daddy sounds
like you're right it's totally like a 14
year old teenager it's the girls
freaking out those teens on tumblr you
know they get mad about a lot I mean
being a teenager is hard and I got mad
about a lot when I was a teenager so
it's like I get it but like maybe cool
it it's gonna affect their exams like
eat a piece of bread maybe you'll calm
down some carbs and taken down yeah what
was that I was like my girl you heard it
here first
this became another fire I definitely
don't need to add fuel to but I'll do it
anyway if you've seen this like outrage
over game engines that started a day or
two ago someone unlike some some I think
it would I think
neogaf had posted something about
someone saying there's a comment on
steam and a comment saying oh as soon as
I see unity engine in the game
description I just don't buy it and then
this sparked like a huge see I was sued
I was way too busy um you know paying
attention to the daddy drama so I don't
really probably good but wait out this
dumb engine fight Wow
well hot dads are strolling about cool
so Evo was last weekend my stuff there
you know catch up I believe we have some
recap stuff up on GameSpot ish for if
you're fighting game fans
yeah Richard Lee just got back from
Vegas he's now in our back room he's
behind the camera doing a lot of
production stuff all every single week
but now he's back in business
cool so moving on soon to eight out of
ten on gamespot I have a few broader
questions I do have some things I want
to get into but first Kellie Plaga you
gave it an 8 out of 10 I think everybody
here except for me has played it in some
capacity but what is uh was the deal
with this game why'd you give it an 8
out of 10 um well so I don't know did
you play the first one at all no yeah so
the the first Platoon I played of course
like playing on a wii u was so
cumbersome because i had like that was
the only game i really played after a
while so number one like having it on
switch i've been saying this about
pretty much every switch game but like i
really do think that good hardware makes
a difference and that does help my
enjoyment but the main thing is like
this this game makes a lot of small
tweaks to the splatoon formula that go a
long way so single player is improved
that's probably one of like the the
biggest changes as you can now use like
every weapon on every weapon but in the
first game like you only had access to
one weapon in single-player and it was
kind of like okay well what's the point
this doesn't really introduce me to any
of the types of weapons I can use versus
in the single-player they make really
good use of you know a full catalog of
weapons it's you know smart fun
platforming challenges we talked last
time when we talked about splatoon about
like rail grinding is really cool one of
the things that disappointed me is some
of those cool like platforming and
movement challenges present in the
single-player they just don't make it
into multiplayer I hold out hope that
because they Nintendo has said that they
will be releasing like free updates for
splatoon which they did for the first
game as well I'm holding out hope that
maybe they'll they'll you know add
something that makes good use of some of
the coolest parts of single-player but
you know even even without that the
multiplayer is still super fun I think
turf war is a really
YOUnique really just you know
interesting and kind of quirky take on a
shooter mode and you know you're just
basically inking the ground and and then
you know taking it so you can't win
based on like which team covered more
than that yeah like you don't win based
on kills I mean you are splatting
opponents but you're you're trying to
ink turf and I think that's really cool
you killers you to be successful on a
run a constant basis everything you're
doing is contributing like is a benefit
to your team mm-hmm like you don't have
to kill someone for that to be a thing
and like it happens every five minutes
and you're like finally I contribute it
it's like yeah every single little thing
you do makes a difference yeah and
that's one of the the best parts is you
know turf war battles are three minutes
long they're really quick you get in and
out of battle really quick you're not
spent you're not spending a lot of time
waiting in lobbies although during the
review you were because there were so
few people playing but you know it's
quick in-and-out and you're even a
defeat you don't feel totally like like
I never wanted to rage quit because I
kept losing because you are getting
rewards you are contributing and the
pretty much a lot of the time like if
you're playing with a bunch of randoms
who don't really know what they're doing
that was frustrating yeah because it's
like okay why are you inking over the
same things I already inked go a
different way please but for the most
part like it's consistently rewarding
you go out with the money you earn even
if you lose you get some reward
experience and in cash and you can go
buy new gear and so that constant like
feedback loop is something that I think
works really well it doesn't feel
repetitive because every every match is
different mm-hmm there's just a lot to
like about it it's a very simple concept
but I think with everything combined
like is you know do I prefer going for
you know look being aggro do I prefer
getting into combat or do I prefer
inking like there's always something to
do and you can kind of shift your
strategy based on your team so I think
there's a lot to like I will say that
multiplayer still has some logistical
hiccups for me you can't change your
loadout in turf war which is like that's
the it's such a small it sounds like
such a small complaint but that
frustrates me to no end because if
you're are all Chargers which is like
the sniper in splatoon you're done
you're gonna lose like that's not a good
weapon for inking you're gonna
it may lead to death and it's gonna suck
you have no way to see what your team is
carrying you pick one at the beginning
and you're stuck with it you pick one
before entering the lobby so you you can
but before you enter if you and this was
frustrating especially during the review
because you know the only people playing
right now are reviewers and treehouse
people you have your team and you want
to change your weapon and you're gonna
lose all those people and yeah and if I
have if I want to change my weapon like
my chances of getting into a game when
there's so few people playing that was
really low but also I mean that's going
that's going to be mitigated when people
are playing the game but um that was
frustrating and it's also just like if
you're stuck with bad team comp you're
you're done like it is it doesn't seem
to be a reason for it yeah there's like
no reason you can't just like an
oversight uh you could in the splatfest
so that's another thing where I hope
that's an update that they roll out I
mean like if I I don't know it's just
like weird Nintendo decisions where it's
like you know why are you doing this why
are you making multiplayer harder than
it has to be why can't I why do I have
to use an app that can only be let's
talk about that little voice chat
there's yeah people and people were
tweeting at me like I don't see why
that's a problem I I think no voice chat
is a positive it's like yeah because
2017 this is watching in the app is only
only available if the app is open and
your phone is unlocked which is
ridiculous to me because a change of
phone settings if you want to get out of
you know that's gonna drain the [ __ ] out
of your battery right you can't like if
you want to switch over to you know text
somebody you like come join our game no
you can't do that you'll lose your chat
if you want to you look up a walkthrough
you can't do that either
he calls you or yeah if your mom is like
are you alive you're like yes there's
there's no way to justify or make this
like seem like it's reasonable a
Nintendo sparked you know it's it's very
bad
it's inelegant they screwed up yeah
there's no apology you can't make any
apologies for it it really is like you
can't even say oh but there's a slew it
doesn't matter there's it's it's the
most ridiculous cumbersome workaround
that I could have imagined because like
you also can't get game audio through
the app so you have to get a special
dongle that connects to both your
controller
your phone so you can get both which is
like why would I do that that's the
other workaround just high volume on
your TV yeah and then your friends get
the feedback or what so it's just that's
frustrating
couple that with the fact that like now
the new iPhone doesn't have a headphone
jack charge and the some arguments in
favor of not having like readily
available voice chat we're like oh
Nintendo wants everyone to have the same
experience but this is a multiplayer
team focused game and I can't organize
team comp especially in ranked yeah so
this is ridiculous this weird dong if
you need an infographic
to show us how to do something that
every game just allows you to do with
yeah and it also other thing is the
switch has parental controls so if
you're a parent and you don't want your
kid to you know like here you know the
f-word you can just do that in the you
don't have to make it so like voice chat
isn't available for everyone just
because a kid might hear some stuff they
shouldn't hear like the parental
controls are already there you know what
your kids are probably playing call duty
you're at their friend's house you're in
the [ __ ] anyway probably watching porn
at their friend's no anyway damn dingo
and the twitch I had mentioned yeah he
was asking is the chat and a good
doesn't sound like it is is that well
okay we'll say I download the app and
the actual like splatoon info was pretty
cool like I was able to see like all my
stats and like my last 50 games and like
which ones I wanted with which weapons
were like handy an app yeah so that part
was cool but the voice chat part I'm
like not down with but it does remind me
of the Destiny app and that I just kind
of want to look at it when I'm not
playing like look at so colorful and
cute and look at my gear so I there's a
use for it I guess you can also see
which maps are in rotation which is nice
if you like really hate a map you're
like I'm thinking about playing right
now and you're like I really don't want
to play on not that I don't think
there's any maps like that in this game
but I do know and you would know a
Callie like as far as the I guess you'd
call a quick chat on the left side of
controller right you can be like I
follow me
like there's only two there's booyah
there's a booyah which is very useful
Booya those were more emotes than like
me occasion yeah well there is like a
this way right this way is a couple but
I even that it's like I don't even know
which way you were 42 I don't looking at
like what you're doing and so yeah it to
the point of like you know you look at
rocket League which has a phenomenal
quick chat system I think so no it does
I was thinking about what I do with Oh
what we do yeah so I'm trying to say is
that for something like turf war right
we're like one of the problems is when I
was playing I feel like we would be up
against for people who like were amazing
I knew what the hell and they talking
communicating the problem I was thinking
it was like when I had that team and you
know you're interfering you're trying to
cover your side of the map and then one
of their guys comes around and starts
like wrecking your side that you were a
pain yeah the only two commands I feel
like that would be used for like I'm
attacking or like I'm defending or some
form of that we're like hey I'm just
gonna roll back literally with the
roller and just manage our side like
that's it that's there's your roll cool
that guy's doing that like I don't know
like the tactics I mean just seemed so
frustrating when I someone was playing I
like it took me a while to understand
how to how to like get into it ever like
what I should be doing yeah what what
your role is I mean like I was playing
in I mean around here we had four codes
so we would play in the same room and I
would just shout out things like like
it's unlike we were playing a MOBA I was
like I'm going mid or whatever it is
some of the maps are like lay bebe's
based not like in the way that you know
Call of Duty has moved to Lane base but
like there are you can kind of go in
different stretches
yes stretches are like a vertical you
know you can go on a different level
than somebody else and kind of double
your effectiveness so I think like
discord is a much better solution than
yeah like the frustrating thing though
is in splatoon at least with turf war if
you join your friends lobby you aren't
guaranteed to be on the same team
so I like I would do this it's the same
as splatoon one like I'd be in
Skype chat with people and then like
three of them would be on the other team
and they'd be like Cali mute us because
you still can't like squat up you can in
League battles so this is this is they
did try to fix it for some modes and I
do appreciate that there's like a casual
mode that's like jump in jump out that's
not a lot of pressure it's about like
having fun and you still want to win but
you get rewards for losing so it's fine
there's ranked battle which is returning
it has 3 modes ones like a capture the
flag like reverse capture the flag ones
like almost like overwatch like you're
escorting a tower to a point
what is reverse capture the flag exactly
have you played like it's like assault
in Halo really you bring a bomb too so
rather than like rescuing a flag from
their base you bringing one thing but
it's like a plant bomb yeah I was on the
exact same wavelength as you would that
I've been watching halo stuff that was
weird sorry but yeah that was cool um on
the same wavelength and then there's one
that's oh you're controlling zones kind
of like ecologies domination so you're
controlling by inking a certain area and
then you're trying to get all three or
however many there are and you have to
hold them for a certain amount of time
and then the game's over and you guys
win in order to unlock League battle you
have to be ranked be- or above in ranked
battle in any mode to get to rank values
to be level ten and turf war multiplayer
like you have to play to her floor first
then you get you reach level 10 you
unlock rank then you get B minus u
unlock League League is the new one
where you can party up with one or three
other friends so it's in groups of two
or four and that one you are on their
team and you can be in chat but it's
it's it's it's who - its - yeah I don't
want to be hyperbolic but that sounds
like a nightmare to figure it out I mean
I'm an adult way through 12-year old me
would be like screw this like is that is
that meant to basically mix up those
those early like matches where you have
those like you know heavy experience
players on one team
just like wrecking job if it's gonna
make I don't know I mean spitballing
you're like is there is that like for
that I'm sure there is a Nintendo style
justification for it
I wish that turf war I could play turf
war with you know in league battle but
League battle using ranked battle modes
like turf war is always casual you can't
be like I'm super good at turf war and I
want to party up with my friends and
there's just I mean I feel like we're
being super negative I did give it an 8
I think it's really fun I it's the kind
of game as a shooter fan that like kid
me would have gone crazy for and that
current me is also super obsessed with
and I can't wait to play when more
people are online and because right now
you can't get a match because all the
reviewers did their reviews and now
they're not playing because it's there's
like six of us but I mean yeah it's just
I hope that they patched some of these
multiplayer things out or figured out I
don't know if Nintendo will because
they're notoriously bad with online it's
just frustrating when it's like okay
this is a team based online Focus
multiplayer game yeah why is this
difficult for you yeah to clarify we're
not like against using discord or Skype
chat which are both viable options she
seems weird that they wouldn't include
it in the game because I mean even like
if I was if I just had a switch and I
was like like stuck to Nintendo stuff I
don't think I'd be too familiar with
discord if I wasn't like a PC gamer but
of course you can download skype easily
and we're not and I'm completely
advocating doing that if it's gonna help
you play this game but doing you could
just do a group phone call on your
iPhone yeah like whatever there's so
many ways to get around it the point be
should have to figure that out the point
being is that this problem was solved
probably at least a decade ago consoles
and here it is Nintendo with their fancy
schmancy look at our cool system it's so
different and unique but it's missing
this really basic thing that you guys
are all used to that is classic Nintendo
that is almost essential to like a
higher level performance in this type of
game right like you guys if I go in with
like I said team comp is a really big
problem that's probably the biggest
problem aside from voice chat I know not
everybody cares my voice chat the team
comp thing is a glaring issue or you
cannot see what people are carrying into
battle you could end up with everybody
has the same weapon and y'all are
screwed there was one thing I really
liked playing the weapons were like way
more in depth than like I ever imagined
were like in the single-player I was
like oh this charge kind of sniper rifle
was like my go-to
I mean
my first like few hours soon player like
this is grand like Krang Mon lanes
Sarah etc and then into the multiplayer
like I was like this gun sucks against
people and I cannot shoot anyone looks
like a high skill ceiling yeah it's a
pretty long charge and obviously like
it's really precise as far as aiming
however what was really interesting was
was it's why I boarded that and I saw
and one of the enemy guys like about
five matches later
he's just in the middle of the map and
he said there and he's just creating
lanes for his team but he's like not
moving so you just kind of like you see
I mean Christ days like all these
weapons like I see someone using it or
applying and I took away I'm like oh
damn like that's how you use that gun
you're just a team player it was like
really cool to to just yeah I mean again
like you know each weapon has like so
many different applications yeah yeah
like I said I feel like we sound very
negative I do say a lot of positive
things in my review that's one of them
is like they made these really small
tweaks to weapons that like I'm still
figuring out the best way to use it the
the charger you can which is actually
pretty popular in multiplayer if I
remember correctly it is a difficult
weapon to use but like the fact that you
know somebody can be really useful
creating lanes because you know going
through the ink is how you reload so
somebody who's like like who needs to go
to the front lines or whatever or who's
on offense like needs the charger to set
that up for them like that's really
smart or on it works really well on
certain maps like more eight hours it's
like that there's a lot of verticality
on that map having a sniper is really
good they also made it so you can hold
the charge in ink which makes you more
sneaky and I just made a lot of song
huge and as a returning splatoon player
when you see that stuff it feels like
this isn't just it's not a reskin right
it's been redeveloped in some ways yeah
they like really really weighted weapon
it seems like balance and you know how
you use each weapon to Inc versus you
damage its you know there's like new
weapons like the Dooleys which is the
first weapon to add movement a unique
movement so you can do a dodge roll
which is which is cool because you're
you're more mobile while not in
which is the biggest or even in your
enemies ink yep you think otherwise your
your squirt low as molasses yeah they
also added new abilities to gear which
is really cool because you know as a
returning player I'm like oh that I'm
gonna figure out a new combination that
works for my new play style with this
weapon that's been changed and so
there's a lot to dig into if you're
returning but it's not you know a total
overhaul and it's this it's still the
fun like already good game that it was
if you had if you didn't play on Wii U
and I would highly recommend it there's
just some frustrations that's my thing
it's good because speaking personally
and I'm sure I'm not alone in this I
wasn't super into the Wii U I don't
think it was like a failure like a lot
of people say but obviously the switch
is doing much much better sales wise and
just reception wise I think I can jump
into splatoon with the second one right
I don't have to go back to the first one
it sounds very much like you do not I
mean the it takes place I think two
years after the first game but I mean
like the Lauren splatoon is very like
hidden under the surface wank wank
overwatch I'm destiny if you yeah and
like so if you want to dig into it
that's cool you're not you're not gonna
go in being like what's happening it's
you know does a really good job of you
know getting you right into it cool
so splatoon - eight out of ten on
GameSpot reviewed by Kelly plaguey you
can go check that out if you want to
read more in depth or watch the video on
YouTube working spot cool alright last
segment get into destiny - beta the
closed beta we here at GameSpot have
been playing it Kelly you got the chance
once you finish the platoon jump into it
did you get the chance play your review
in a few I just pick up a surprise
review which I'm excited about
yeah but we got a chance to play
yesterday include is the first mission
story mission much of which we saw at e3
then we also got to play a strike
andromus are you playing a bit of
competitive PvP kind of crucible stuff
yeah but Dana I didn't scream there was
actually a bunch of areas in this first
mission that were kind of surprised yeah
you know Eric very much our resident
destiny expert was I got to stream with
him and he was like oh this is new this
is new like new enemies here yeah I will
say except if you want a much much
deeper dive into a lot of the
like statistics and if you're one of the
kind of player who plays destiny to
min/max everything go watch that stream
eric has a lot of good insight for that
for the purposes of show we want to kind
of give Everly impressions how the game
is functioning as a sequel but yeah we
did get the chance so just to set the
stage for those of you who didn't get a
chance to play it yet we jump in they
give you a chance at a character class
they give you like three kinetic weapons
to choose from so we can get into the
how the weapons are divided now as
opposed to the first game if you don't
already know but yeah you get in you do
the first story mission you pick hunter
or warlock or Titan and they're the new
subclasses that we can talk about but ya
know this is obviously gonna carry over
you get an exotic like five minutes into
the story mission but this won't carry
over until the game or into the game's
final September release but yes sorry
Rob we let's talk about the story
mission while we're watching b-roll we
saw a lot of this at e3 it's the this
faction of the Cabal who you first
encountered on Mars in the first game is
attacking the last yes city what by Ghul
and there's like they're called the red
Legion they protect the traveler as well
super it's kind of like Halo 2 has that
Splinter Cell of the elites or the
Covenant of The Heretic if you want to
yeah there's sort of like a separate
lambent in Gears of War yes this third
faction breakaway kind of rogue thing
but yeah they're attacking the you're
defending the last city the the tower
the Guardian is sanctuary and here you
have the arc Strider one of the new
subclasses for the hunter which I played
bo staff you also have this new the hunt
war sorry the hunters have a new Dodge
that can reload your weapon a la McCree
from overwatch be familiar it's really
cool I was a hunter main in the first
destiny so as you should be oh well I'd
say would definitely argue with me on
that but yeah warlocks
I mean warlocks are no just kidding
taste of Titan mate I'm just messing
with him he's not here to defend himself
anyway I I do like that change I think
it's something that's gonna be really
cool to get used to is that like dodge
reload timing mmm that I'm excited to
you know kind of get more acquainted
with yeah but I love arc strider yeah
like it way more than Golden Gun for
sure and then there's also the Titan
Sentinel which is like cap
America or Athiya if you played
Borderlands the pre-sequel throws a
shield kind of a few passives based on
that like it's chained enemies in like
ricochet off walls yes it's worth
talking about how the subclasses are
kind of structured now so there are four
passives you can go down like two
branches and each subclass four passives
they group the four together as opposed
for the first game where you can kind of
just mix and match everything mark
Noseworthy on if you did get the play
the closed beta mark Noseworthy went
more in-depth on twitter he's a producer
for the game yesterday I believe on he
was describing how like it's a a little
more you know like the four passives are
meant to be stuck together and like as a
subclass of the subclasses a little more
defined now rather than you being able
to swap as much yeah but I interviewed
him during e3 and he talked a lot about
the weapons classes if you're curious
about that I think yeah you get a little
more flexibility so it's kind of you
trade one for the other yeah you want to
explain that so as opposed to primary
secondary power that's what it now it's
very heavy now it is kinetic power yeah
so kinetic like a salt rifle submachine
gun scout rifles well any any type of
not any type of weapon but weapons that
could be primaries or secondaries can
like secondaries are included in energy
and kinetic is literally anything with
Trude conventional bullets yeah and then
energy is more like elemental a fusion
rifle used to be a yeah it's like solar
and then power is like the you know
sniper rifle grenade launcher yeah yes
so they've they've moved things around
and he describes that more in detail in
the interview which you can see on
GameSpot now if you're curious but I do
like that because like I was using this
hand cannon because that you get that
it's an exotic that you kind of get as
part of this demo pretty beta but I
never used hand cannons but because of
the new organization I was I picked it
up and I actually really liked using it
yeah so it introduced me to more weapon
types that I kind of would have ignored
because I was always a scout rifle
person and so you know you can have a
kinetics
scout rifle and then an energy hand
cannon yeah
I you get to use a wider variety of
weapons which is really really cool I
like it a lot or two hand cannons yeah
can anyone share you probably like I
don't know if you'd want to put that but
I could do that which is super cool and
you know if you're really big into hand
cannons you know if you're trying to get
I don't know how the grimoire will work
but like you know you unlock grimoire by
getting certain amounts of kills and
with certain weapons mhm mhm um so who
knows if that's gonna be a thing but
yeah yeah that would be a reason to do
it I guess it was want to have that
different weapon type right like when
you see a guy with like a shield or some
kind of like element base just to like
switch to that weapon to remove it and
it's just back like I I enjoyed that
kind of system yeah it was yeah it was
nicer to be able to like okay I'm gonna
switch to my energy to take down his
shields and I'm gonna switch back to my
kinetic whereas that would have been you
know going into the menu in the first
destiny so that made combat a little
smoother for me I want to say that well
while we're still looking at the footage
for the single-player mission that I
really was intrigued by the direction
the story's taking and I won't spoil
anything if you haven't played it I
guess but um I was like okay destiny I'm
listening like I feel like you're more
committed to story this time around I
feel is more of a narrative here so it
was a Luke Smith the head of like
destiny to was saying that I mean it was
it was more of a kind of tongue-in-cheek
thing he was saying he hopes people get
annoyed with how much story they have
that was that was a big complaint I
think when before does anyone came out
everybody saw this really like stylize
really almost noir looking sci-fi world
and we were hoping there would be a lot
of story supporting it but of course
it's all you know push to the periphery
for people it's more of like it's more
based around the mechanics and these
systems of this shared multiplayer
shooter but now yeah like you said there
are definitely hints in this first story
mission of much more characterization
you here you see Zavala here you're
fighting with him and a Korra you see
her up ahead and of course cayde-6
plays into it but yet you but like you
said they actually set up a cool story
at the beginning which is I didn't think
I would say yes if you you know like I
was really big into the grimoire when I
first started playing destiny and so
it's just
cool to like not have to hunt for those
things they're there for you already
even though like being in the tower area
and seeing it all decimated is really
cool as a returning player it's just
nice to know that they're actually going
to put energy into that because the
systems are so good I really really love
the systems in destiny I love the
shooting so much said that lots of times
but I feel like it's more balanced now
yeah we do have some Twitter questions
about this game there's a bunch of them
that came in on throw yesterday but I do
like that it was all most of them Bungie
saying hey we're destroying the place
the social space from the first game
we're moving on it was kind of a good
way to start the game I guess good
message oh yeah and we did get to play
strike as well which was the inverted
spire I have mixed feelings about the
strike I haven't had a chance play
strike yeah you did right I did yeah
what I didn't like the boss fight as
much but I do like leading up to that so
you know like we you know you drop it
with two other players I play with Nick
and Jake yesterday
here's Tay and Rob playing right now it
stays using the Sentinel Titan class
with the shield as I mentioned before oh
I thought you were telling me that
wasn't the Kelly was just shaking her
head wait was in my peripheral vision
but yeah I'd like to strike leading up
to it it was cool there's like this
massive you can go watch the whole thing
and I won't spoil anything like too much
but there's some there's some
platforming which I could have done
without but it was it was very but it
wasn't like obtrusive it was just a
normal destiny platforming which I
always have problems with but then
there's some cool parts that actually
incorporated the well the map design in
like you have to like avoid
environmental things that were actually
kind of making you think on your toes oh
cool the thing I would say about
platforming I mean I I hadn't played
nearly as much destiny one as I should
but like what would cut through me off
was just like you know you're playing as
a character that has what like each care
each class has like three different ways
of managing your jump system right like
I just I found it difficult to like
platformer in that respect right it
wasn't familiar with the jump right like
we know like the Titan has one works
like you can you can lift but you have
to disengage right so I was
when I play with two randoms they
probably hated my guts because I kept oh
yeah no I mean just from my point of
view as someone who played a lot I think
this game still feels phenomenal better
honestly I this game feels better than
any shooter ever played still and it
remains here in destiny too if you you
can go more in depth on the mechanics of
this game while you want because they're
so refined and you kind of have to and
it's a game that's repetitive and people
have been maxing and whatnot you have to
make it feel good it still feels very
good I just don't like when they force
platforming into things which I forget
which raid it was I think was the taken
king raid when there was actually really
heavy platforming in one part like
between three checkpoints actually one
part so it's not that bad I just
I usually dislike when shooters force
platforming in but it feels really good
to clarify yeah I mean like I'm not
crazy about the platform me either
there's also a section in the the story
like the story mission that you have to
do this like weird platforming thing
with this like generator that I wasn't
crazy about mmhmm yeah that was kind of
tricky it's just like I don't know
especially as a hunter because you're
pretty floaty I mean I warlocks are
floaty estate I know I had a pretty
floaty jump and I was like this is
irritating but it was very short it
didn't like ruin it right um it's still
like you said it still feels great there
was an area in the strike that I kind of
liked I had like a mix of platforming
and you know like you're dealing with
snipers like I I didn't necessarily mind
the strike I did kind of find that
that's that story one that you were
mentioning did definitely frustrating I
died a lot I got a lot - on that yeah
but whatever yeah we yeah you get the
you fight a boss later on and it becomes
there's a little more platforming kind
of vanilla platforming but it it still
feels like a destiny boss you know
you're shooting it for while there adds
to replenish your super and to get ammo
and it was fun it makes you move around
I just had a few problems with the
actual kind of map design that I was put
on but that was just like I guess what
it really I don't want to spoil it too
much if you don't even if they're not
gonna show the boss fight I just don't
think it was the it was the best use of
an actual boss arena and some of my
favorite strikes they actually make
really good use of it
what was his name maybe take and shut it
over it was the vex boss from Destiny
that you're in a circle and their shield
walls pushing you and then you actually
eventually he goes to the middle and I'm
kind of waiting for tyre gentlemen but I
just don't think this strike boss right
here you can see it was just seemed very
there were some cool parts right here
you see that the floor lights up and you
actually have to avoid the damage from
that I just wasn't really thinking about
much besides shooting him and it just
wasn't the most intricate design Boston
it's kind of a maybe too much criticism
the level at a boss and a beta but it it
both well it felt like a well-designed
strike just one of my favorite boss I
guess mmm but I'm looking forward to
seeing more from that Rob you played
some competitive pvp yeah yeah we played
on the stream played some more after I
went back and I you know tape someone
again who's fairly new to dusty yeah
destiny I would say yeah you know what
class is right for you so to speak and
take was saying Oh like you know I look
Titan because he's a big tight advocate
but yeah I was i I did another run on
with Hunter and I like loved hunter as
far as the mobility factor yeah I feel
like I cherish that like far more like
just being able to move it like that
Juke roll you can do like I saw
basically I saw people doing that when I
was playing as Titan in PvP and I was
like I need that I need to be able to
like get at dodge and like just Juke
someone and so but I did have a good
time I with the PvP as far as like
enjoyability factor I don't know like I
was definitely like not doing well when
I was within the first few matches but
because it's very different like I'm you
know one to like love halo and and
you're I kept thinking like I was
playing Halo you know what I mean but
it's yeah really not like there's a lot
of verticality as far as like the just
the jump system in general like I was
getting worked by people just who were
just above me ya know whatever I found
very different whatever Bungie did just
refine their movement I mean I played
halo 5 recently for the first time in a
while and it's amazing how much better
destiny feels in Halo 5 I mean some
others and it's not the same
they're the same vein of shooter yeah I
mean it's it's just honestly that's like
I said you have to make this game feel
good for the amount of time people are
gonna spend in it and it does like to
the tenth degree it feels amazing still
and like yeah you know you have as a
hunter main as well you have the dodge
you have like I just put the triple jump
on immediately because they start you at
level 20 with 200 light I think yeah I
just I'm a the triple jump feels
phenomenal you put the strafe jump on if
you want a little more control you can
put you know it's it's it feels great
still you no worries there at all and
this I think overall impressions this
beta actually has me more excited to
play destiny too than I initially was
definitely definitely I shouldn't say
the strafe jump is probably good for PvP
to get anything for as far as changing
direction midair yeah yeah I do have a
couple questions I want to get to before
we dive back in or just end the show
Adnan Ahmed on Twitter said as a person
who never played destiny why should I
care why not just wait for anthem which
looks like it will combine destiny with
narrative we touched on anthem earlier
talking about Casey Hudson going back to
Bioware can't speak too much to what
anthem it will be because we still don't
know a ton but you got time yeah yeah
and I think yeah like I said it kind of
made me want to play destiny to more
someone who played a lot that's me but
if I hadn't played destiny I think you
don't really need to play the first one
you could just jump in with to kind of
like splatoon me too we was talking
about it seems like it's made to just
introduce a lot of new people yeah I
mean I think your incentive is if you
like shooters like this is a
mechanically really impressive shooter
it feels great to play yeah as someone
just played tons of shooters like I just
I have lots of problems with destiny but
I just keep going back to it because it
feels great yeah it's funny to think
like yeah like when I was playing
yesterday like it's just such a awesome
mix of like sound design and like just
you know everything from the rumble and
the controller of every weapon like how
it feels it's one of the things where
you know I don't know if that's like a
gripe against destiny but like how many
times you know you're kind of doing the
same thing right yeah just like bullets
smudging like a boss however it's I've
kept thinking like man I feel like I
could listen to this gun like for an
three hours I sound so good and like
each weapon is very unique as far as
feel and again look and yeah I like it
it's really fun yeah I like how spongy
the enemies are I'm just like I don't
know I just there's so much to like
about even just shooting a wave of
enemies I don't know how to explain it I
feel like it something you have to try
on this yeah you know this flow state
playing that game that's just like hard
to find out where yeah yeah so odd not a
Matt I think this is a good time to jump
in if you're interested in the first one
and didn't like kind of really get too
far into it doesn't eat - seems like you
know that like we said it seems like
they're addressing story concerns from
the first game and taken King did that
as well they really characterize cayde-6
i Correns of all of the Guardian leaders
the Vanguard leaders but here like we
said we don't spoil anything but if you
play the story mission you can see them
setting up some really cool threads that
has more characterization than anything
in the first destiny so yeah Adnan thank
you so much for your Twitter
contribution we have another one from
Julian Davis can you see yourself
spending as much time as you did in d1
with d2 the Destiny formula is kind of
punishing and makes me ask why bother
question yeah I mean it seems like for
me personally who played a lot of
destiny not as much as like Tay or
anyone but I do I like kind of games
that I do like games with repetitive
structure I like Diablo 3 I like games
where I can know what I'm getting into
destiny 1 felt like I got too much to be
like chores for me but two seems like it
might spend maybe not as much time
because I understand what destiny is now
I understand what taken King did I'm
just curious to see what destiny two
changes broad-strokes
would you've kind of gotten like taste
stuff so far
I don't know Pio you always want to get
in tustin you did play destiny but with
taken King you played a little more but
from what you've seen in the beta and
everything do you think on what
September 6th it comes out do you think
you'll you'll like give this another
shot
yeah no I mean I didn't play destiny
only because by the time I realized that
I should be playing this game it was way
too late people were already just like
running with it and I feel like yeah the
game is beautiful has some interesting
story stuff plays really well but so
much of it is that shared experience you
have coming into work talking
friends about it just you know owning
this like this this topic and I couldn't
do that
so with d2 I can just do that from the
ground level and yeah just having this
opportunity to start from scratch it's
great it becomes like a a weekly or like
a daily ritual like that's how I caught
up with my brother for like two years
honestly like playing destiny and like
we would go in and again it would feel
that if the game didn't feel as good it
wouldn't work but that's how I like you
become like this group almost it becomes
like a like a book club honestly seems
like a good opportunity yeah that's what
I was missing with destiny I didn't
really have that that's why I didn't put
as much time into it I'll definitely put
more time into to than I did one just
because I didn't have that I joined with
taking king and then I went back and
played vanilla stuff with this it's like
oh I'm starting on the same footing as
everybody else which is why I like that
your character doesn't transfer over
because it's almost like a clean slate
for everybody definitely now I don't
feel behind I don't feel like I'm
constantly catching up and trying to get
to that next light level so I can do
something with a group of people who are
way ahead of me like all of my friends
were ahead of me
so that's something I'm looking forward
to that's right and I remember when I
tried to start again like six months
later actually one of the funniest
things is when I first started again
like six most later I like joined like
you do that intro mentioned and then
you're at the tower right and they're a
bunch of really high level guys who
songs like hey buddy come over here and
get this ghost home in and I felt like I
was like in high school it seems like a
bunch of seniors like giving me [ __ ] or
something and and then you start hearing
from like other people here like oh you
just started oh you have 20 hours in
order to do this and so forth where it's
like oh like once you start hearing that
and you don't have that group to join
you right and you're just doing it by
yourself it's like I don't I can't I
don't want to do it yeah yeah so yeah
we've got the chance to play the closed
beta a little bit if you have early
access your pre-ordered game you might
already been playing as well Friday
everyone can play I believe Xbox one
open today at 10:00 a.m. I'm not
mistaken PC will be sometime later this
month or next month they haven't
announced a specific time on Sunday
starting at 10 a.m. PST the social space
the phone
the new tower so to speak will be open
for an hour I believe they're stressed
testing it if you want to check it out
and go play soccer or something and just
hang out with a few other people you
could do that 10 a.m. PST so that's
definitely - I think overall good
impression so far yeah I'm more excited
than I was I think it's beta served its
purpose for me personally
mm-hmm I'm more excited for destiny to
that I was saying yeah cool that's our
show
giveaway as you might have seen Shiva's
in our twitch chat right at noon and
just posted we're doing a strafe
keyboard god damn it I hate straight
gaming keyboard oh you want more sir so
yeah as usual if you don't follow game
spot on Twitter go do so retweet that
specific tweet so this dumb face can get
more out there than it needs to be I
have a pimple on my nose in that photo I
hate this everything about it yes now I
see it so later on later on the week
later on the week
gamespot will pick a random winner from
the people that retweet that tweet
that's our show cool that was that's
ratchet a plushie by the way a bunch of
people were asking throughout the show
I'd never found a good time to break it
up I don't know why Rob put it on his I
did not cool can you talk about where
you were reviewing no cuz I already kind
of gives some sort of response to it
oh that you're liking it a lot yeah I
played it for 13 hours yesterday destiny
- nah just kidding the game I'm gonna
play for 13 hours yesterday and I could
have kept just the first thing I wanted
to do this morning was keep playing in
one day you played 13 hours yeah you dog
mystery game
yeah yeah it's soon it's great I can't
wait to talk about it on Monday next
week yeah your view goes on Monday so
will clearly be talking about it a week
from today on the lobby I'm sure in some
capacity what do you guys playing
destiny - more until around the weekend
what are you playing me Rob huh playing
Mima lose destiny - titanfall to update
Tuesday 4 player co-op board north we
will Wednesday oh man
one of the bigger changes coming to
titanfall - I'd say you like do you do
you play I told you dude man yes yeah
it's a for feller horde mode we'll talk
more about it Wednesday what
not prolong in his show with final to
chat fine are you excited yes I am
member lasts or a few weeks ago when I
was saying it's time to come back
titanfall to guess what
I was lying up date
it does look fine they keep ramping up
man like you saw the weapon skins they
had and they look so cool those like
give it XP boosts but the the biggest
thing is this co-op mode
we're like if you were intimidated by
the multiplayer at all like you know as
far as feeling outmatched this is like a
really cool wave based thing or like
bunch of new stuff like apparently like
new Titan upgrades that you kind of
amount to with like cash and currency
and throughout each game yeah there's
like different different difficulties
like there's like an insane so there's
like obviously like normal hard and then
master and there's like insane
difficulty what is that right yeah I'm
really excited so yeah next week Tuesday
we'll check that out
maybe stream it I was telling you it
take it takes a good shooter to get me
excited for a horde mode in 2017 but it
looks like it'll be fun
yeah that'll be coming out Callie you
gonna be playing splatoon too now that
more people are out in the wild with it
oh that comes out Friday July 21st I'm
visiting my parents this weekend so I
can get me when she gonna come on the
show and debate me oh my god I'm not
gonna touch that right now so I'll be
able to take my switch with me which is
why I love my switch so much and so I'll
be playing that in the evenings and I am
playing destiny obviously and yeah I was
gonna say something I never mind I'll
also vague Peter not here our streaming
Zelda once again yeah so we sure mode we
stream every day at 11:00
Rob and Pete have been doing Triforce
tough Triforce yeah they were doing
master mode hard mode and Zelda breath
of the wild so check back in for that me
and Jake have started a we used to that
we were trying to like play the games
and talk about in reboot our show on
Sundays but now we decided because
people seem to like it and watching us
die we're gonna play some player knowns
battlegrounds for the next few weeks see
how it goes
we both have gotten our decent Sheriff
in dinner's Jake's got more than I have
that game is fun it's fun to watch yeah
it is I mean it's that game has made
some like unknown streamers careers in
the last like few months speaking of
news though the doctor disrespect got
banned yeah I need to play that game I
had a dream that I was playing Bala
grounds and I literally never played it
because I'm afraid that'll be terrible
oh I'm terrible it's just fun yeah I
don't like xbox one sometime this fall
they're saying hopefully the desert map
will be out semi soonish who knows when
and then there's another mediterranean
map they're talking about right now it's
just that one Eastern European eight by
eight kilometer map which a lot of
people know really well after playing so
much yeah cool so Triforce tomorrow
yeah I don't know what Joey and jean-luc
have planned for Friday they will too
now splatoon two more splatoon as Joey
says no not that splatoon to his backing
I was just looking forward to seeing
what game they whatever trash they as
usual thank you so much to you gentle
psyche Eric Tay and Richard Lee in the
back thank you to everyone who joined on
Twitch YouTube or GameSpot will be
covering more destiny to throughout the
week splatoon - I'm sure we'll talk more
about the game Pete is reviewing but
we'll have a lot to talk about next week
maybe titanfall - and we'll be back at
the same time
Wednesday 11:00 a.m. we'll see you then
[Music]